Republic
this is the French President removing
his luxury watch during an interview
where he's telling the workers or
friends that they're just gonna have to
sacrifice a few more years before they
retire and he's doing this while France
is quite literally burning to the ground
more than 3 million people took to the
streets in a nationwide general strike
with numerous fires and incidents of
looting reported in the southwestern
city of Bordeaux someone Set Fire to the
front door of the city hall there city
services have been shut down garbage has
been piling up on the streets for over
three weeks protests have erupted with
Millions joining in and hundreds have
been arrested in the biggest Uprising
the French have seen in a good amount of
time all because the president of France
macron is trying to increase the
retirement age from 62 to 64. why has
president macron forced this through
Parliament without so much as a vote the
answer the spiraling cost of French
pensions age 62-64. this may sound like
just a small and significant issue
across the Atlantic but this this is a
forewarning of what's the con America
because America's retirement system is
also a giant ticking Time Bomb just like
Francis this bomb just so happened to
explode in France verse but if we don't
make some changes fast we're gonna soon
be in the exact same position and no one
is covering this 57 million Americans
work for an employer that does not offer
a retirement savings plan it comes as
the U.S slowly raises our retirement age
to 67. Social Security benefits could be
cut by 2034 if Congress doesn't act
quickly stay dangerous and let's get
into it
[Music]
I know we're starting to make a lot more
videos to cover stuff like this faster
for you guys which means we're going to
have a lot more sponsor spots available
and I was thinking about it and I
thought if we're going to be promoting
more Brands we might as well promote
your Brands being that a lot of
entrepreneurs watch this channel so if
you run a company or you manage the
marketing spend of a company and you
want to be featured in one of our
responsive spots send us an email at
business jtrend.io that's business
jaketrain.io in the description below
now back to the video
[Music]
many see the fights over pension as the
last 10 defense of France's social
welfare model France has been having a
rough time lately food prices have gone
up by almost 14 over the last year
consumer goes like hygiene and cleaning
products have gone up by just as much
energy prices have gone up by over 40
and overall prices have inflated by 7.3
percent in the last year the strongest
search for France in the history of the
Euro area so to the French people
raising France's minimum retirement age
was simply the last straw the last slap
in the face amidst all this pain and
suffering because it goes against the
very essence of French culture as the
classic saying goes in America you live
to work but in Europe you work to live
and France is the epitome of this life
is about living not working that's why
France has a strong minimum wage that's
why France has Universal Health Care and
it's why France has by far the lowest
retirement age out of other European
Neighbors in Italy you have to work
until you're 67 before you can start
claiming pensions Spain the UK and
Germany are all around 66 years old but
France and France you can retire at just
62 years old and all of these generous
social benefits aren't just nice the
house for the French people the French
people view them as what they're
entitled to it is their natural rights
as natural of a right as the right to
free speech is for Americans so put
yourself in the shoes of a French person
you've spent Decades of your life
working putting in the hours you've been
having a rough time these last few years
you've been paying the second highest
income tax in all of Europe at a
nauseating 55.4 percent all with the
expectation of hey I'm paying all these
high taxes so I have a cozy retirement
at the early age of 62 and then boom
some politician comes into office and
expects you to sacrifice another two
years of your golden years by raising
the retirement age from 62 to 64. if
this was you you are gonna be enraged
you're gonna go on strike protest Break
Stuff set stuff on fire but here's the
thing about social programs like public
pensions is that they're not free
there's not some magical money tree that
sends you a monthly paycheck once you
retire no all of those retirement
paychecks old people get are funded by
younger citizens like you and me money
gets taken off from the workers and
employers it gets put in a giant bucket
and then it gets paid out to the old
people but here's the thing not even
Fritz's super high taxes can support
this very generous retirement system the
problem is that French people spend less
time working and more time in retirement
than most of their European peers
leading to funny shortfalls that
increase the public debts meaning that
even with some of the highest taxes in
Europe there's not enough retirement
money to go around on top of that
France's retirement system originated
all the way back in 1941 and in 1941 the
average French person expected to live
around to their mid-50s today the French
are living well into their early 80s and
yet they expect the same retirement
system to be able to pay more people
living 30 years longer than before the
bucket is simply not big enough to feed
all the cattle and an aging population
is making the problem worse one key
measure is the old age dependency ratio
the number of older people compared to
the population that is working age in
Europe and North America that ratio
would be about 50 per 100 people by
2050. according to un forecasts a rise
from just 30 per 100 people in 2019 in
short we are on a trajectory towards a
smaller share of people paying taxes and
a higher proportion drawing pensions
without change France's national pension
deficit could balloon to as much as 0.8
percent of annual economic output over
the next decade according to the
country's pensions advisory Council
that's a liability The Government Can
ill afford in a country that already has
one of the highest public debt burners
in Europe so something's got to change
with the French retirement system or
else it is going to implode and there
are only four options number one you can
raise taxes even more number two you can
print more money basically doing the
same thing number three you can anger
the old people by decreasing their
monthly retirement checks or number four
you can make the working class work
longer before they're able to retire or
in other words you can increase their
retirement age the French President
chose the fourth option and the working
class we're not having any of it the
masses don't care that the pension
system isn't sustainable that's
eventually going implode that eventually
Something's Gotta Give they just want to
kick the can down the road so they can
retire at 62 so they stopped working
went on strike and took to the streets
we're here today because it's out of the
question to once again raise the
retirement age you have to understand
that some people work in difficult
conditions and today these people are
told that not only do they have to work
longer but also nothing prevents the
government in the future to restart this
type of Bill it's time for them to
understand that people also want to
enjoy their lives we're not here to die
on the job we're here to be able to
enjoy life one day too and America is in
the exact same position
foreign
[Music]
our public retirement system is called
Social Security except there's nothing
very secure about it see Social Security
was created by FDR during the Great
Depression when there was no safety net
for the old and the sick the problem is
back then old had a very different
meaning much like France back then the
average life expectancy in America was
only 62 years old and the government
only allowed you to get Social Security
money once you reached age 65 a whole
three years after the average person was
expected to die that's why Social
Security was never meant to be your main
source of retirement money and nobody
ever expected it to be it was just to
help out the very old but as we started
to live longer this little support
system for only the very old became
something that I'm entitled to quote 50
years ago the average retirement was 12
years someone retiring today at age 65
is expected to live to 85 years older
longer that's 20 plus years of
retirement and that's the average many
will live vlogger and have 30 years of
retirement so once again the same bucket
is expected to feed more and more cattle
more and more cattle that are living
longer and longer and yet none of the
cattle seem to care they're all
continuing to mindlessly wander around
in hopes that everything is going to be
okay
unsustainable retirement promises now
total trillions of dollars but nobody
cares nobody was paying attention
there's a reason why in France no
president has tried to fix the
retirement problem for the last quarter
of a century this is going to be a big
deal a lot of people are going to be
hurt we just don't have enough money and
the amount of money that we have to put
into this is just mountainous but soon
the cattle will erupt in chaos just like
they did in France this is why once
again you do not want to be dependent on
the governments and all of this the
pension Bond the banking crisis the
Trump drama the loss of faith in our
political system it's all setting the
perfect stage for our enemies to come
together to take us down and we're gonna
cover the newest major move they just
made in the next video so subscribe by
clicking the circle on the screen while
you're waiting learn how the US got to
its position as Top Dog by financially
enslaving the entire world by clicking
the square on the screen everyone should
understand this piece of history that
they don't teach you anywhere else so
click the square on the screen to watch
now
[Music]